world leaders meet in Paris on Monday
for a crucial summit on climate change
and we'll all be asked to cut our
greenhouse gas emissions that means
giving up on petrol and diesel will be
driving two alternative green
technologies here from the sky news
studios in West London all the way to
the conference in Paris it's our own Eco
rally I'll be driving the first hydrogen
powered car for sale in Britain this is
a version of home dyes ix35
and our being the best-selling electric
car today that's the Nissan Leaf my car
turns hydrogen into electricity and has
the same range as a petrol the Nissan
Leaf has a realistic battery range of 80
miles we'll need to plot our stops
carefully
Thomas is heading right towards failure
I'm gonna head just for hydrogen filling
stations in the UK luckily one's closeby
well the fueling point might look a bit
different but the process of cleaning up
is much the same as petrol plug it in
and that should in three minutes give me
enough hydrogen to take me all the way
to Paris fingers crossed here we go
we are seventy two miles in and down to
nineteen percent battery time to charge
up first charge of the day let's give it
a whirl
that's quite satisfying clunk their
vehicle synchronization you don't get
that in petrol be very futuristic we're
gonna have to leave this for around half
an hour's but that is now charging we'll
leave it we'll go get a coffee come back
when it's done hopefully this is where
the race is gonna be one Tice's start on
a failure because he's got a hydrogen
car he's not allowed inside in case it
explodes well tom was boarding I wasn't
far behind all right cheers then but my
crossing takes an hour longer and I've
just missed my ferry chance for a
catch-up I've got loads of hydrogen left
I tell you once we're on the French
motorways we're just gonna get so far
past you
the first two frauds couple
well we've arrived in France we've got
170 miles to go to Paris and we've got
241 miles of hydrogen let's go where are
we what is this I mean middle power I
mean this isn't very close to the
motorway it's putting us back it's not
the most convenient place that there and
there's an initialization error and this
takes not even really worried about
losing to Tomas there's more just being
stuck here in the little e lovely French
countryside for quite a long way away
from any source of electricity Cheshire
and Tim electric are almost out of juice
they were sent on an SOS
Oh Tom gonna have to consider this point
Thomas observations what actually
happened it's just the car is great
infrastructure is not up to it
our journey finished here and a service
station 50 miles into France if electric
cars are going to be a viable
long-distance option the recharging
Network needs to improve we pressed on
to the conference center our finishing
line a normal car would have produced
enough carbon dioxide to fill a large
van but we've emitted just water vapor a
victory for Team hydrogen and the
climate